infinite scroll is a feature that can
have a huge impact on the user
experience by loading data
asynchronously based on scroll position
in this video I'm going to show you how
to implement infinite scroll and angular
with the firestore database but we're
going to do it in a way that not only
allows you to scroll down to load
content but also to scroll up and load
content in the opposite direction this
has been a commonly requested feature
and it would be used if you were doing
something like Facebook Messenger or
slack where you load a timeline of
messages in Reverse we're going to
accomplish this by creating a generic
service in angular and it will not only
retrieve the data but also tell us when
we've reached the end of a collection
and when we are loading new data if
you're new to the channel make sure to
subscribe and grab the source code for
this project from angular firebase comm
I'm going to be starting from a brand
new angular app and it's only dependency
is angular fire so make sure to go to
the documentation and follow the setup
instructions there then the next step is
to create a directive called scrollable
this is going to tell us whether or not
the user is scrolled to either the top
or bottom of the page we're going to do
that by monitoring the scroll event on
the element itself that'd be that
container element and then we're going
to omit our own custom event that will
tell us whether or not it's the bottom
or top you can create a custom event and
angular by using the output decorator
and event emitter so our custom event
here is named scroll position then I'm
going to add element ref to the
constructor but I want to warn you that
using element ref for direct Dom access
can cause issues in angular with
platform server and web worker we can
address this issue by wrapping native
elements in a try-catch block then
provide a fallback such as a load more
button when the Don doesn't actually
exist first we'll set up a host listener
on the element then listen to the scroll
event so keep in mind that your host
element needs to be something scrollable
and we'll set up a function here and put
our try-catch block inside of it
then we need three values from the
native element itself we need scroll top
scroll height and offset height first we
need to know if the user has reached the
bottom of the element so we can do that
by saying top greater than height minus
offset minus one extra pixel when that
condition is met we
our event emitter send out a string
value of bottom four top we can simply
see if the scroll top is at zero before
we go any further let's make sure this
works in an actual component so I'm
going to switch over to the app
component then I'm going to import
observable as well as the pagination
service which we're going to create the
next step then I am setting up an event
handler here that will just console.log
the event from our custom event in the
directive all we need to do is set up a
div and inside that div will add the
scrollable directive and then for the
event we use parentheses with the scroll
position event and then we'll run our
scroll handler and I'm going to add an
extra div in here with some height to it
just so we can actually scroll through
this parent div if you watch the console
to the right you'll see we either get a
bottom or top event once we've reached
the bottom or top of the element itself
and before we get to firestore let's
generate a component called loading
spinner then head over to spin kit and
choose your favorite spinner and just
copy and paste the HTML and CSS into
that component before we build this big
complex pagination service I want to
show you how it's going to be used in
the component to paginate in fire story
you need to send a new query for each
new batch of data that you need the
service I'm creating will allow you to
make a query with some basic
configuration options and this will
populate an observable on the service
that we can subscribe to the first
argument to an it is the collection and
the second is the field that you want to
order by you can order the collection in
Reverse and you can also prepend new
items to the beginning which is what you
would use if you're doing an upward
infinite scroll after the initial query
we'll listen for events in our scroll
handler once we receive the bottom event
we can just call the more method from
the service and that will populate the
next batch of items from firestore so
the service we're building will give you
infinite scroll with just two lines of
code the service will also give us a
data variable that's an observable array
that we can loop over with the async
pipe so we'll display some information
about our boats in the database but the
service also has two other variables
that are important the first one will
tell us once we've reached the end of a
collection and that's the done variable
so we can listen for that
and then say I ran out of boats once we
reach the end we have a another
observable that will tell us whether or
not a new query is loading so we can
show a loading spinner for each new
query and that also helps us prevent
sending multiple unnecessary queries if
we take a look in fire store quickly we
just have a boat's collection that's in
the route and each document has a URL
and a year field so we'll be sorting by
the year when we look in the app we get
the initial loading spinner and then
once we scroll down the loading spinner
will reappear and about a second later
we'll get some new data loaded now we're
finally ready to start building the
service we're going to need angularfire
store and we're also going to make
pretty heavy usage of rxjs behavior
subjects next I'm going to set up an
interface that defines the query
configuration options so we have a
required field of path which is the path
to your collection and then we have the
field that you want to order by then
we'll set default values for limit
reverse and prepend prepends the
important one that's the one that you
would use if you wanted to have the
items at the beginning of the array
instead of added to the end of the array
next I'm going to set up a few behavior
subjects the subjects are all private
variables and they have underscores so
you can keep track of them easily in the
code done will tell us once we've
reached the end of the collection
loading will tell us when a query is in
process and data is the last batch of
information that has been retrieved from
firebase then we'll set the query
configuration as a variable so we can
keep track of it between queries and
that'll be typed to our query config
interface then for each of these
subjects we're going to set an
observable that will be consumed by the
component this will keep all of the data
changes isolated to the service this
part is technically optional but it is
considered a good practice all we need
to do is call as observable on the
source data then the next step is to add
angular firestore to the constructor
then we're going to go through a lot of
code here so I recommend checking out
the main article for detailed
explanations on each of these methods
the first one we'll set up is a knit
which is going to make an initial query
as well as save our query configuration
on the service it requires a path to the
collection as well as a field to order
by and then it has optional defaults
here that you can override by passing
them as an object so we'll set a default
limit up to and then say reverse false
and prepend false now we can use this
object to make a reference to the
firestore collection we're going to
order by the query field if the reverse
property is set to true then we'll go
ahead and order it descending otherwise
it'll be ascending then we'll go ahead
and limit it by whatever set in the
query configuration then I have a map
and update method that I'm going to show
you in just a second here but first I'm
going to show you how we define the
observable data that will actually be
used in the front-end component so we'll
take our source data and then we'll call
the rxjs scan operator on it scan allows
us to build a larger array over time
if the query options are set to prepend
then we want to take the new value and
concatenate it to the beginning of the
array and if it's not set then we just
want to go ahead and concatenate it to
the end scan is a pretty weird operator
to learn so I recommend going to rxjs
marbles and checking it out visually now
let's take a look at that map and update
method it takes the angularfire store
collection and then Maps it down to the
snapshot that we need and then sends it
to our main data source if the
collection is already done or loading we
don't want to make the query so we'll
just return out of the function but
otherwise we'll set the loading state to
true and then we'll call collection
snapshot changes to paginate a cursor
and firestore you have to use the
document snapshot so what we're going to
do is map down the array to the data
that we want to show on the front end as
well as the snapshot you'll see in a
second here how we use the snapshot to
offset all future queries then after we
have this data mapped down we're going
to check and see if the prepend option
is set then we need to reverse each
individual batch to maintain a
consistent order going in Reverse there
may be a better way to do this but I
wasn't able to figure one out for the
upward scroll when you're pre
new items to a list after we have the
values mapped down we'll go ahead and
update them in our main data source at
this point we can set our loading state
to false and we can also check to see if
that was an empty array at which point
we know we have reached the end of the
collection and this is going to be a
one-off operation for each new query so
we're going to say take one and
subscribe this will end your real-time
connection with firebase but pagination
with real-time data introduces a whole
other host of issues and trade-offs that
you have to think about it's beyond the
scope of this video but please reach out
on slack if you want to talk about it
now we're ready to set up a method to
make secondary queries so first we need
to know the cursor that we want to
paginate from if we're a prepending we
want the document snapshot from the
first item in the last batch otherwise
we want the last item in the last batch
if the array is empty we want to return
null otherwise we will get an error from
firestorm the more method is going to
make all subsequent queries first we
need to get the cursor for the
pagination and then we'll create a
firestorm reference it's identical to
the initial query except that it uses
start after and passing that cursor as
an argument
this tells firestore where to offset the
query from then once we have that set we
can call a map and update and our data
source will be updated that was a lot of
code to get through in 10 minutes but
make sure to check out the full article
for detailed explanations on all these
methods my goal is to give you a generic
service that can work with any firestore
collection and give you infinite scroll
either upwards or downwards that's it
for firestore infinite scroll with
angular if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and if you want twice
as much content every week consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase comm you'll get exclusive
content a free copy of my book and one
on one project consulting thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]